SPEAKER: Service accounts--
where do they come from?
In the last episode, I mentioned
that there are some service
accounts that are
created automatically
for us, like Google-managed
service accounts and default
service accounts.
That's really nice,
but you might want
to know how to create your own.
After that, how will
you manage them?
What will you do when you
need to get rid of one?
These questions
mean that it's time
to talk about what's what
with creating, managing,
and retiring your
service accounts.
Creating a service account is
as easy as one gcloud command--
gcloud iam
service-accounts create.
Upon creation, this
new service account
will have no rules assigned,
so zero access to any APIs
and services.
Before we talk about assigning
roles and permissions,
let's iron out the creation
process a little bit more.
Every service account
should have a purpose.
One of the best best practices
that you could practice
is to make sure a service
account's purpose is
clear to you and to any
other administrator that
might inherit your
project in the future.
So when you create
a service account,
make sure that you include
a descriptive display name.
If you want to take
it a step further,
and I recommend that you
do, you can include even
more details and context in that
service account's description.
When creating service
accounts, make
it a habit to figure out
a meaningful display name
and description on creation by
tacking on the --display-name
and --description flags
to your gcloud command.
This will be especially useful
if your project accumulates
a long list of service accounts,
each with a different purpose
and set of IAM roles
assigned to it.
You can view the display name
and description for any service
account using gcloud iam
service-accounts describe,
followed by the
service account email.
You can always update
these fields in the console
or by using the CLI with gcloud
iam service-accounts update.
When you have service
accounts in your project,
a big part of managing
them is managing
the IAM roles and permissions
associated with them.
If you're already familiar with
Google Cloud's IAM policies,
then you might already know
that checking what a service
account is capable of doing
is as simple as checking
the IAM policy of your project.
gcloud projects
get-iam-policy followed
by your project ID will
show you all the IAM role
bindings on your project,
including the roles assigned
to your service accounts.
Service account
management doesn't only
mean understanding what
resources service accounts have
access to, but also who
has access to your service
accounts.
When you're taking a
look at your IAM policy,
take note of any
accounts that have
roles associated with managing
or using service accounts.
This includes predefined roles
like Service Account Token
Creator, Service Account Admin,
and Service Account Key Admin.
Some of these roles
will allow users
to make changes to, or even
act as, service accounts.
That means it's technically
possible for a user
that you intend to be
restricted to have unrestricted
permissions via a service
account with bloated access.
It's a security topic that
we'll cover in a later episode.
In addition to the IAM
policy on your project,
there is also an IAM
policy for each service
account in your project.
The role bindings
on these policies
are limited specifically to
their corresponding service
account, and are not visible
on the project's IAM policy.
You can retrieve a particular
service accounts IAM
policy with gcloud
iam service-accounts
get-iam-policy, followed
by the account email.
All of this role
and policy info is
available from the Cloud Console
under IAM and Admin Settings.
There may come a day when
you'll want to get rid
of a service account.
You could just delete it.
But beware-- once you do,
any users, applications,
or VMs that are configured to
use it to access any resources
will lose that access.
It is important to use caution
when deleting a service
account, especially
if you're not so
sure about what it's used for.
It's much safer to
disable it first.
Once an account is
disabled, yeah, applications
will lose that access
that they had through it,
just like when you delete it.
But a disabled service
account can easily
be re-enabled at any time.
Does that mean that when you
delete a service account,
it's completely,
totally, utterly,
and hopelessly lost forever?
No, not exactly.
You could undelete a
deleted service account,
but only if two
things are true--
one, the service account
had to have been deleted
within the past
30 days, and two,
there can be no other
service accounts
in existence on your
project with the same name
as the deleted service account.
That's because disabling
a service account
will reserve the name,
but deleting it will not.
After you check the service
account's details and roles
and decide it's
probably not in use,
you can disable the service
account with gcloud iam
service-accounts disable.
If it turns out that the
account is needed again
for whatever reason,
enabling it is as simple
as gcloud iam
service-accounts enable.
Otherwise, you can
delete it with gcloud iam
service-accounts delete.
So we talked about how we can
best create service accounts
by providing them
with a clear purpose,
and how to safely delete
them by disabling them first.
We also talked about
managing their access
by checking the project and
service account IAM policies.
That's only part of what goes
into managing service accounts.
Next time we'll expand on
that, and talk a bit more
about securing service accounts'
roles and IAM policies.
See you then.
[MUSIC PLAYING]